how's the conference going all right so
he told me I was supposed to start by
telling my story but he just told my
story so hopefully we can maybe make the
speech part of this a little bit shorter
and do a little bit more QA so basically
there's a big black box in the middle of
my story there's probably a message in
there somewhere but you can read all
that so I'll just do a quick I'll do a
quick voiceover I am I was born in the
cornfields of Illinois and spent my
childhood doing a bunch of things that
you do in the cornfields it's really
nothing that would prepare me for a life
of entrepreneurship and then I went to
college I was in the college in the late
90s everyone here is way younger than me
were younger than that and my class was
the first class in my college that was
assigned an email address I thought it
was a pretty interesting at the time I
studied applied math one of my biggest
regrets is not studying computer science
I I think I should have and I mean
applied math is plenty hard enough but
for some reason I decided not to do that
one of my friends on Thanksgiving of our
senior year reserved a domain name
called the spark com it started putting
up some content and he sent me a link to
the content and said you should check
this out and I was like this is just
silly
so I ignored it and I went through the
through the regular recruiting process
and I ended up getting a job with the
consulting firm and I was all set to
become a consultant and then he emailed
me again and he said hey Sam have now
got a few hundred thousand people
visiting we had unique visitor we didn't
have Mau at the time we had unique
visitors and he was like hey I've got a
few hundred thousand unique visitors you
should really check this out and at the
time in the late 90s it was still there
were still so many ideas that hadn't
been
now you kind of have to be really
creative to start a new company you'd
have to like create some app that does
something that you've got to like
concoct - two or three ideas together
but at the time there were just all
these obvious things that hadn't been
done yet and so we started this company
called the spark Tom we'll get into more
of that later but we basically pivoted
that business to be sparknotes we sold
that company we got very lucky we sold
the company six weeks before the market
crashed in 2000 I sold it s/m said for
way too much money and then the company
we sold it to another business eleven
months later so that's what you get for
buying a company for way too much money
a lesson to be learned but for some
reason has never learned by acquirers I
didn't started a company called edonkey
anyone here remember edonkey okay a
peer-to-peer file-sharing that was a
very interesting ride for me get it okay
it was a very interesting ride ended up
getting sued by the record labels for a
billion dollars testified before the
Senate Judiciary Committee started a
lobbying group to try to lobby Congress
so we got a whole bunch of war stories
about that that I'm happy to talk about
actually when I got an MBA which I know
is generally scorned and looked down
upon in the tech community and then
decided to go back at it and start
OkCupid with the same founders that I
started sparknotes with we sold the
company to match while it took us like
eight months to build sparknotes into a
business we could sell it took us eight
years to build OkCupid into business we
could sell sold it to match and then
expect it to do my year at match and get
out that's when most entrepreneurs do
when they sell their company but the
folks that match took a huge gamble on
me and offered to make me CEO of match
and I went from one day running a ten
million dollar business with 30
employees to running a billion-dollar
business with a thousand employees all
around the world and that was a huge
huge learning experience for me I spent
three and a half years as the CEO of
match while I was CEO of match
we most famously incubated tinder and
grew it into one of the most successful
startups really ever it's certainly one
of the most successful startups that
come out of a corporate come out of a
corporation we spend about a billion
dollars on acquisitions around the world
and then we had an IPO last November
so that was my that was my three and a
half year run as CEO of match and then
thanks and then while I was doing all
that I mean I moved back to Chicago and
I'm very passionate about the Chicago
tech community
so I started what is now tech star
Chicago and we've graduated 60 companies
through that program in the last six
years and then I started a small little
venture capital funds called corazon
capital where I really have a totally
different approach to how the
relationship that VCS and entrepreneurs
should have together and I think my my
sixteen years as an operator I think I
bring a very different approach to to
how to mentor and how to develop great
entrepreneurs so that's kind of what
I've been up to but they asked me to
talk about content is it commodity
you've heard both contents just a
commodity or content is king so I'm
gonna take you way back into the 90s to
our site called the spark calm and we
again in the span of just a year became
known as we want basically a dozen
Awards as site of the year in 1999
because of our contents and here's an
example of some content that we wrote it
was called the fat project we found Eric
and Nicole and we offered them three
thousand dollars if they could gain 30
pounds in 30 days how many of you think
you could gain 30 pounds in 30 days
that's impressive okay so basically this
was like reality TV before reality TV or
reality internet before reality internet
we took pictures of them in their
underwear every day for 30 days this is
it I won't take you through all 30 days
you can find it on the Internet
here's day 15
let's go back to zero day 15 get in
there all right so here's a question if
this is the zero and this is day 30 do
you think either of them made it how
many of you how many of you think Eric
made it how many of you think Nicole
made it now so it turns out your guys
are kind of wrong Eric made it Nicole
didn't and what Eric was able to do is
really nailed a 30 I mean he gained 6
pounds in the span of two hours which is
pretty impressive and so you can imagine
we were just we were kind of doing this
every single day
and this became a total viral sensation
on the Internet
so he said okay that fad project was
pretty cool what else can we do so we
did something called stinky feet where
one of our Christian rudder who's now of
okay trends Fame tried to give himself
athlete's foot
he literally like walked around like
locker rooms and shower stalls and with
no feet on for 30 days
stinky meat we just put a plate of
rotting meat out in the yard and watched
the maggots that's all good stuff and
then we did stinking meat too because it
was so good to do stinky meat one so
this was an example of a business that
you know based on content generated a
ton of value in just a few months we did
something else called these personality
quizzes we were really the first company
in the 90s to do personality quizzes
you'll see this was not the final
tallies but these quizzes were taken
over a hundred million times in one year
this was pre social pre any of the sort
of built-in virality about systems that
we now have today this was all just
sorry this is all just on the quality of
the content that we built and then we
built ecards ecards were a thing in the
90s one of my favorites just think about
it
and so the problem with this kind of
content though is that you have to
constantly produce humorous content and
we this we realized by the time we
decided to become a company but even
before we incorporated as an as a
corporate entity we decided the humor
business as a crappy business to be in
because you have to be funny every
single day so we thought to ourselves
well what other business can we be in
we've got all these millions of users
what else can we do and so we looked up
I was in Chris's dorm room and we looked
up and he had CliffsNotes up on his
shelf and my other partner max just
looked up and said we should do
sparknotes we didn't do any market
research we didn't do any ideation on
the name the name just kind of came to
us and we started making sparknotes and
we find we found ten of our English
major friends and if you English majors
you know so it turns out turns out
English majors will work English majors
will work for free almost so we
basically went to these English majors
and said you just spent $100,000 on your
education paying our school to let you
write papers we're gonna pay you to four
hundred dollars to write a paper for us
and so these ten English students went
out on their spring breaks and they
wrote sparknotes and they get brought
them back we put them up on the site and
we got all this hate mail from our users
who said I can't believe you don't have
my book which is great it's a great kind
of hate mail to get and so we went we
produced another one hundreds of Park
notes over the summer and launched and
really in the span of one year killed
CliffsNotes
which had been around for fifty years
now a lot of people ask well sparknotes
wasn't about the content it was just
because it was free and so it wasn't it
was a commodity but there were tons and
tons and tons of study guides out there
and yeah we were better marketers yeah
we had a better brands but at the end of
the day you know it was a no-brainer to
students that we were better and it was
even you know pretty clear from
professors and and journalism and
journalists that sparknotes were the
best and so that pair of businesses the
spark and sparknotes was the business
that we built in 11 months and sold
first to an Internet company called I
turf
then later to Barnes and Noble so
OkCupid his business I've been working
on for the last god 12 years I feel bad
for anyone trying to do dating
businesses they're really hard and the
hardest part about them is how do you
build critical mass right how do you get
the liquidity and the way we did it was
with contents we went back to the well
of this of the quizzes that we had built
it at the spark and we said well let's
build an online dating personality tests
and let's make the personalities that
you can get really really funny so we
had 32 different personality types units
to read all this the conference
organizers said you can't have more than
50 words on a slide it's like who makes
that kind of rule so anyway I think
there are more than 50 words but I'm a
rule breaker I don't know what to tell
you
but we had all these different
personality types and people would post
their personality types all around the
web and that was how we drove a lot of
traffic to okay Cupid in the early days
we then said well let's let's keep going
down this content road and let's use
contents to help people find their
matches at the time a harmony was one of
the market leaders have you guys seen
the eHarmony commercials with the old
guy and the granddaughter isn't that
creepy so I've never understood that
marketing concept but we bit yeah right
though we basically let people write
their own questions and these are just
eight questions that I found and we let
people all right
I have no idea what you're saying anyway
we're gonna go to okay so basically so
so we let we let users create the
content and then we created algorithms
that sorted the content sort of the
questions that allowed the most
interesting content to come to the top
these are just some of the questions
actually very interesting questions if
you read them and think about what your
answer would be and then what you would
want a potential date how you'd want a
potential date to answer those but we're
gonna take a quick segue out of this
conversation and do some audience
interaction okay so show of hands how
many people enjoy horror movies okay
have you ever traveled alone in a
foreign country okay and wouldn't it be
fun to check it all and go live on a
sailboat okay of the thousands and
thousands of questions that are in our
database those are the only three that
predict relationship success if you and
a potential date both agree yes yes or
no no on these three questions you are
statistically more likely to end up in a
successful relationship okay show of
hands hoops sorry show hands for men if
you would answer yes to any of the
questions on the left under men please
raise your hand men and leave them up
for a second okay
women how many women like the taste of
beer okay hands up keep your hands up
everyone who's raising their hands right
now
are statistically more likely to have
sex on a first date
so hopefully you paid attention to
there's a little party tonight right so
hopefully all of you were paying close
attention to that back to the regularly
scheduled programming so we have all
this interesting contents all right and
so we and we knew that yes we were using
this content to drive to do improve our
matching algorithms who were using this
content for targeting ads but we thought
we can really use this targets this
content to go drive more traffic and so
we did what many people do and we called
a PR firm and this was the friendly PR
firm that we called schwartz
communications up in boss
and they said great we'd love to take on
the account and so we started mining our
data and one of the first pieces of
nuggets one of the first nuggets of data
that we got was that when gas prices go
up people narrow their search radius
super-awesome right like it's like after
you say it out loud it's obvious that
that should happen but it actually
happens right that's so cool
and so I was like so excited right it's
like yes we have this great finding we
had Schwartz called a hundred
journalists every one of the hundred
journalists was like oh my god that is
so cool and every one of the hundred
journalists said I'm not writing a story
today on the effect of gas prices on
dating called me back next week with
your next little nugget and so we did
this over and over and over again and
for a year for six months and no one
really ever wrote any stories about the
things we wanted them to write stories
about and so we said well screw it we're
gonna you know will pivot we'll try
something else we'll iterate and so we
started blogging and it in the blog ok
trends became ultimately super famous
but it took us a while to get our
footing and I should say I should give
all the credit to Chris and Christian
who did the writing I just get to talk
about it we first thought that we would
have to be really provocative with our
talks and so this was the very first
blog post we wrote and I remember
thinking when it went up
I remember thinking wow do we really
want to like we're trying to build like
a dating brand that people feel good
about do we really want a rape fantasy
to be the thing that everyone associates
with OkCupid and but but you know
Kristen Christian were very they said
look we have to be provocative we have
to go out there and we have to like sort
of scream real loud to get the attention
first of all some super interesting
findings
I mean Wyoming
who know um anyway y'all might sit here
yeah okay
I'm sane right so this is this was the
very first blog post we did but it turns
out that that actually wasn't what we
needed the data was so powerful that
first finding of like gasps and and and
yes prices in search radius that kind of
stuff was actually much them ended up
being much more compelling it just had
to be packaged the right way
these ended up being some of the most
successful blog posts that we wrote and
you'll see none of these are clickbait
none of these are artificial none of
these are especially provocative but
these are these are the kinds of posts
that we put up that got millions and
millions and millions of of shares and
reads and views and there was a time in
the summer of 2010 where we were
literally on the front page of a Sunday
Times section three to three weeks in a
row
one was Sunday style one was arts and
one was business were somewhere the New
York Times is basically just saying this
content is unbelievable I would argue I
would argue that the blog probably is
this primary reason why we were able to
sell our company and probably on its own
in the span of a few months probably
generated I don't know 20 30 million
dollars of equity value to the business
and with that that's it so we I'm two
minutes early so we get two extra
minutes of Q&A or we can all go drink
faster all right
be better with a mic
it's probably an obvious answer but so
with the the weight challenge you said
you would pay them if they reach 30
pounds or increased 30 pounds I'm
getting a guess that you get a Pitts you
pay them anyways right we definitely
paid Eric cuz he made it yeah we
probably yeah we give Nick we yeah we
paid Nick oh yeah wow that's the
question
alright hey Sam yeah in today's age
Internet's flooded with content what are
the bloggers that have tons of knowledge
about tons of things but we don't know
what's important how would you stand out
I think ultimately this goes back to my
belief in the power of brands you know
and and I kind of look at this through
like the dating contexts right it's not
exactly a blog which is not really the
world I live in right now but like you
know how many dating honey how many
dating businesses have launched in the
last decade hundreds do you know how
many dating business has launched in the
last decade have any any noticeable
amount of success one right and if you
think of liquidity and users as content
right it ultimately gets back to the
fact that like all these all these
businesses didn't know all these dating
businesses didn't build brands right
they just found they thought they had
like some slick way to get a few users
or whatever but they weren't building
sort of this lasting permanence and I
think in the blog context you have to
think over a very long time horizon and
just say like you know I want to build a
reputation for being smart or funny or
whatever it is and those people who do
that over time can have sustainable edge
an advantage that you can't take away I
think like clickbait and stuff like that
is all very temporary and then you're
just in an arms race and eventually
you'll lose hi Sam thanks so much for
your talk so quick question about
content content seems like it could be
extremely time consuming
so how do you evaluate the impact versus
the effort of content creation you know
it of course it's a lot of work but you
know I think startups are a lot of work
and work is a lot of work and I just you
know think about producing content
pre-internet you have to actually like
go get things printed and get things
distributed and you know your ability to
you know make video content on the fly
you know use Twitter use you know social
media to get your content out I think
all the more I would actually go the
other way which is because distribution
is so easy now you can spend all your
time on making great content and making
an winning on quality quality is the
thing that you can give you sustainable
edge over time and you know I think too
many people try to shortcut it they're
like oh I just want to get more content
out and that's almost never the right
answer I mean just look look look at the
great content brands out there and think
about how they built it there are a few
that did it on quantity and clickbait
but the vast vast majority are just the
best content out there hey Sam thanks
for chatting with us my name's Gary Ely
and the fact that your blog was able to
increase the value of your company in 20
30 million dollars is mind-boggling to
me it's curious to know you're kind of
answering this as we go but I'm curious
to know how that happened and what
metrics you measured in order to
determine its success in the early days
we measured we had this I remember the
first couple blog posts at the bottom we
we had this sign up for OkCupid and
share sign up and chair and we were like
couldn't figure out what we wanted
people to do because we didn't know what
our metrics were and it turned out that
the temptation was to get people to sign
up for OkCupid right cuz that's what
everyone wants to want them in the
funnel right you want that email address
you want to be able to do all the stuff
you do after you get email address and
it turned out that again I'm a big
believer in brands I think that is your
long-term differentiator and what we
ended up realizing was that all that
mattered about this was getting into
becoming a household name right think
about how many how many how many
startups to actually make it and you
have to get out of San Francisco you
have to go to a cornfield in Illinois
you have to do people like that to be a
great business to be a business that
like is permanent to be a business that
is you know I you know that your kids
will know about you're gonna have to get
to the cornfields and think about that
right and so what we decided was we
wanted to be a household name and the
way to become a household name was to
make sure to drive KPIs and and metrics
and to evaluate keypads and metrics that
had that kind of breadth and reach and
so we were looking at things like how
much press did we get right how many
that that was really the primary thing
that we were cared about how many
interviews every time we did a blog
posts if we'd end up on TV would end up
in the in the New York Times would end
up on all the influential blogs and
there was a period of time in 2010 where
I would argue the OkCupid blog was must
read in the in sort of digital media we
would get requests from journalists to
just say just please give me a
five-minute warning before you post
people were offering to pay us lots of
money to just get the blog post a day
early so they could already write the
sort of you know analytical posts about
the blog posts spark notes and OkCupid
are such different audiences and they're
solving such different problems
what other industries are next for you
that's a good question you know my
current you know I think there was a
thread between spark notes and OkCupid
and that was really sort of producing
best-of-breed content for free with a
brand voice that was very different from
the incumbents that were that tended to
be stodgy or and more conservative
OkCupid sort of really opened up big
data and sort of all the appeal that
comes with that I and I think whatever I
do next I really want to think about how
can we use data to do something else so
whether it's in e-commerce or something
else I'm just super interested in
thinking about data and what else we can
do with it thank you Sam
Thanks